[Music]
i've been doing this a long time and
people would ask me occasionally who
haven't you gotten to talk to yet and i
bumped into you once or twice but really
sit down and talk to and i would say
over the years i gotta talk to dick van
dyke because i think of few people
who
inspired me more when i was a kid i
would watch you the whole way you would
move that sort of thin gangly way that
you would move you didn't gangly yes
yeah that that physicality and i really
think uh there was so much of of of you
that i that i stole wonderful frankly
over the years and butchered but uh just
an
absolute thrill to have you oh thank you
very much i'm a fan you know oh well
thank you
i like the way you move you move pretty
good
dick this is getting creepy
i can't believe i'm up this late
i can't believe we taped this at 11.
play along play along
you know it's funny
um
i was talking about your physicality and
uh your your dancing you know i mean i
grew up on the dick van dyke show and i
remember very clearly
uh and i remembered uh mary poppins when
i my parents took me to see mary poppins
and you're dancing in that movie
completely blew me away so funny and so
original and then i find out you're not
a trained dancer no no i never even
thought about that until i was in my 30s
until i had to
so literally you knew nothing about
dancing and then you get cast in this
role where pretty much you have to be an
iconic dancer you have to be a fantastic
dancer and you just did it
well i had down champion who was the
director and the choreographer by by
verdi
and he said we'll teach him and he did
and it was a discovery like flying i
said where has this been all my life i
just loved it
i was curious too in that movie uh you
do a british accent in that movie and i
realized that i borrowed your whenever
anybody comes on the show who's from the
united kingdom
and it could be anybody it could be dame
judy dench it could be hugh laurie i say
governor
and they get so mad at me and i said i
learned that from dick van dyke oh my
god
i if somebody from the uk sees me
they're on me like a pack of bulls i
mean it was the worst cockney accent
i've ever done but i was
the guy who taught me was an irishman
yeah
pat o'malley
so now i i made up a story i said it
wasn't cockney it's from a little
obscure county in the north of england
yeah a few cockneys moved up there you
know in the 1800s and it's you probably
wouldn't ever hear it again so
so you were completely lying to people
so really the british get angry when
they see you they and and uh do you ever
give it to them right now that's what
i've done so many times right in their
face i go like oh i'm so sorry
sweetie a chimney for you
i will
you were uh such a superb and are such a
superb physical comedian i mean the fall
over the ottoman the beginning of the
dick van dyke show
is
one you know probably one of the top
five
classic
images from television you falling over
that was that
did you know that you could do that take
pratfalls like that oh yeah i practiced
pratfalls the time i was a kid i was a
big fan of the silent scream uh buster
keaton and laurel and hardy so i learned
to fall early and and
so sometimes i don't do it on purpose
anymore
did you get did you get injured over the
years i never hurt myself once isn't
that funny i can still do it only it
hurts now
we won't make you do it thank you no i
will
come on dick do it
so uh you take these falls i know that
you you over the years you've seen other
comedians that would take falls and you
were concerned for them because you
thought they weren't doing it correctly
uh chevy chase as a matter of fact on on
saturday night i mean
chevy would just throw himself down but
he wouldn't tuck he wouldn't roll he
wouldn't hit the ground he just and he's
in bad shape today yeah
he has some back troubles yeah yeah he
hurt himself badly because he didn't so
you actually called sarnot live when you
first saw chevy chase and you said
you should've heard you shouldn't fall
like that yeah
but
i'd learn from guys like buster keaton
you tuck and you roll and
you save yourself